[Musik]
wenn ja auch gut
ich bin hier die küchenchefin und die
inhaberin im restaurant strandhaus mein
name ist günther grothe wall e und ich
arbeite als restaurantleiter hier im
restaurant strand der gast steht hier
immer im mittelpunkt und das ist halt
wichtig dass die leute zudem zum gast
einfach offen und freundlich sind es
kommt natürlich auch sehr sehr viel
fachwissen noch dazu
[Musik]
ein ganz normaler arbeitstag im
restaurant beginnt restaurantfachmann
günther kümmert sich um den gästeraum in
der küche haben die vorbereitungen für
das essen angefangen
[Musik]
das gemüse wird geputzt und geschnitten
die kartoffeln werden geschält
es wird gekocht und gebraten beim
personal essen bespricht das team was
für diesen tag wichtig ist günther und
astrid sprechen über weitere details die
ersten gäste kommen und werden von
günter begrüßt
[Musik]
zuerst gibt es etwas zu trinken während
in der küche schon das essen zubereitet
wird
[Musik]
günther serviert was essen und wünscht
den gästen guten appetit
[Musik]
mehr über den beruf des restaurant
fachmanns erfahrt ihr im nächsten teil
[Musik]